ladies and gentlemen welcome to the tim
dillon show uh starting off a little
seriously
uh this episode uh we've been thinking a
lot about the show and the direction
that it's going in
and uh you know i was out to dinner the
other night and somebody said to me you
know you've never had a woman of color
on the show and this is true and it's
because
number one is because i don't have
guests usually it's a show without
guests
it's kind of me ranting you guys are
familiar but i started to think about it
and i started to think about like
that i needed to kind of make some
changes and why not use this platform
to elevate people that have been
marginalized historically and
why not use the platform to bring on uh
uh
a woman of color to speak i think that's
very important so
i think now it's time to kind of throw a
bone to progressives
listen to people uh reach across the
aisle
you know in in in terms of everybody
should be listening to each other so i
said i was like i
absolutely at dinner i said i 100
am going to bring a woman of color on
the show i think it's the right thing to
do
for somebody like me uh that has a
platform i i truly believe that
i'm not kidding i know i'm a comedian
but i'm not kidding about that
um so without further ado ladies and
gentlemen please welcome candace owens
uh candice thank you so much
for being our first one
you're our you're our first woman of
color on the show and i
and i really am grateful that you came
on thank you so much
thanks for having me i i love being the
first one what a pioneer and yet i feel
that
no it's not going to go as you planned
in the comments section
well i'm just i'm hoping that everybody
recognizes that i'm you know really
trying to
to to elevate someone yeah
is it weird to you is it funny that peop
there is so much
of a push to listen to people of color
women of color
and you who are an author you've got
millions of followers
you you drive the national conversation
when you say something people listen
but no one would ever think to to to for
you
to be the woman of color that anyone
should be listening to right that's
because progressives only like black
people if they're going to complain
about being black and say they're a
victim
and sort of fall into that narrative the
ism narrative as i'd like to refer to it
as racism sexism
um you know whatever it is and because
i am a content person because i like
america because i don't hate white
people because i don't hate men
uh that disqualifies me from the
oppression olympics
so i do find it to be hilarious um
because i think it reveals
who they actually are that it's not
about giving a platform
to black people it's about uniformity um
and
i am not uniform so and
you know what's interesting because i i
observe you you're a happy person
you're happy you're right like you enjoy
your life
you're happy you got a great husband
congratulations
you're pregnant you have a baby on the
way you're not a miserable person and
you don't seem invested in other
people's misery
like you yeah and i think is there a
psychological component
to a lot of politics right now that
we're not realizing where you see some
of these people
when i see somebody with purple hair
screaming i go there
there's something else going on and it's
not always political
it's usually just a mental disorder um
which
none of us are equipped to address uh
you know with trying to make yourself
unattractive screaming shrieking finding
you know issues with everything like you
just anything that you know screams
normal to them they have to attack it
they're just like this needs to go
because it's too normal
um it's a horrible way to live so i
always say if you
look at the life of a leftist um
they wake up every day and they are
trying to figure out what to be upset
about
eventually that has to rot your soul
like you know to be looking around to
walk into a grocery store and be like
you know what
these aunt jemima freaking pancakes have
to go you know what i mean like i look
in and i'm like ooh like what's in the
meat section
see what he's made up um so i just can't
imagine they don't realize the weight of
their own mentality
um and i'm the exact ops person i'm
always happy and that's part partly
because i have a family
um we just have a very good sense of
humor we just always made fun of each
other growing up we don't take ourselves
too seriously
so i think having a sense of humor just
makes life
better and the left just does not have a
sense of humor about anything well
that's true i mean one of the things
there's so many comedians that
do respect you and a lot of them don't
say so publicly because
you really you live by that code
of listen you can say whatever you want
about me i'm gonna laugh it off we did a
video where i dressed up like a corona
ball
and the corona ball said that the corona
bowl was gonna come and go up your nose
and find you in a grocery store and i
know chappelle's talked about you in
other comics and snl you
you really roll with it like you don't
care
you laugh it off i love what you said
about snl i think you tweeted
your show hasn't been funny since 2009
which is true yeah why why are you
able to laugh things off and and why are
so many people
on the left but also you have certain
people on the right just not able to do
it
well you know i think first and foremost
i like i said i love humor so like i
grew up watching all of the stand-ups
and i think it's it's sad
um that comedians aren't allowed to say
um things unless they're politically
correct political practice is not funny
it's just not funny right um so like i
always say uh
it was chris chris rock's bigger and
blacker it's one of my favorite
all-time favorite stand-ups and you if
you watch it from start to finish now he
could have never performed this in 2020
um he would have been burned over the
coals um and what's beautiful about it
is he starts out the first thing he says
is racially charged he comes out on
stage and he's like white people in the
back tonight
then he starts going on about all of
these stereotypes making fun of
black people for the baby mama culture
making fun of white people being like if
it's a school shooter you know it's a
white kid right you know all these
things
like you could never say today and by
the end of it
this incredible thing happens where
everyone in the audience
you no one escaped whether you were
chinese black white
gay straight no one escaped and you sort
of realized you know what
we all kind of suck and we're in that
together and there's there's a beauty in
that there's a humanity in that
and not taking yourself so seriously and
being able to laugh at yourself like i
appreciate
the stereotype even the caricature of
candace owens right so like i found your
thing to be very funny because it was
hitting at this caricature of like
canisters doesn't think i'm real and
that's funny and
i should laugh at that and not be like
how could he make fun of a woman
of color expressing her opinion about
apparently it's just so boring it's
funny
are you ever invited you know when they
do because you will
debate anybody you'll talk to anybody
you'll sit down with anybody
um are you ever invited
to these colleges for these debates when
they talk about
critical race theory or
intersectionality does anybody ever
say let's bring candace in or is i mean
even as i ask the question i feel like i
know the answer because you'll go
like you'll show up and you will bring
your ideas to people
but do you are you surprised by how
little that happens
no i'm not surprised because everything
everything that they believe in is a lie
um it's a misrepresentation um and it
relies on
no one in the audience having a modicum
of intelligence to be able to counter it
or
being too fearful to counter so you
could be sitting in the audience when
the left is
spewing their you know racist sexist
misogynist bs but you're white and
you're straight so you gotta shut up
right right and they built that safe
they built that safe space around
themselves because you just have to shut
up
unfortunately for them according to
their own rules i'm at the top of the
progressive stack so they have to let me
talk
um which means that it relies on two
people locking based on intellect and
the left cannot lock with me on
intellect because i'm going to hit them
hard i know that all of it's bs
so they do what they the only thing that
they can do is pretend i don't exist
is there any is there any really smart
person
whether it's dr cornel west or whoever
where you go it would be a tough debate
like do you ever look at somebody on the
left and go
cause i remember asking i think i asked
ann coulter this i was like and i think
she said maybe it was pacquidell
or uh mickey kaus at one point who's
kind of drifted maybe to the center now
but is there anyone on the left where
you go yeah this is a person who i don't
agree with
but i kind of respect them and i think
they're smart
um so you brought up cornell west i've
debated him right right
i've sat down and i spoke with him and
the thing is is he doesn't play
far left when he's in the room with me
so he actually agreed on a lot because
he's smart
enough not to say ridiculous things and
drive himself to the far left which is
just making no sense right
um so we were able to have a respectable
dialogue and
to be honest now i feel that those sorts
of moderates
have all sort of kowtow to the far left
and their arguments are getting more and
more ridiculous
so there isn't anyone that that is
counting to the far left that i'd be
afraid
to be in the room with and to be i find
much more
fear in debating people on the right um
that i mean like i would never debate
larry elder that is one person that i
have been open about like
thank god we're on the same side because
the man is absolutely brilliant he
doesn't forget a single fact
and i think i think he's got like a
photographic memory from the left i mean
there's
women can be men men can be women like
what do i need to prep for right like in
in a debate about that you know what i
mean like kids should be able to pick
their gender they have the agency they
you know
they can't figure out not to stick their
hands in toasters but yeah sure let them
decide on their entire you know
lifestyles when they're two years old so
they're just so
crazy right now that no there's no one
that i'm fearful to sit down in the room
with right
now you got some flack you you often do
and uh this was about harry styles
wore a uh dress on the cover of i
believe vogue or
vogue a ball gown you get it right a
ball got and now my whole point was that
no one can afford
if you told me tim go get harry styles
dress on a cover of vogue
i mean if my mother was like you know
you're about to kill her i couldn't find
a ball gown i don't even know how to buy
these clothes they're too expensive most
people don't
i talked about it on my show i'm like i
don't think this is such a huge problem
because nobody has a job
but what that was a firestorm so what
about that you saw that and you go
they're trying to get rid of traditional
masculinity do you think it's do you
think it is kind of that plot
or do you think it's kind of just like
harry styles trying to get attention and
being ridiculous like
i feel like there's probably not a lot
of dudes in the country that are going
to start dressing in like christian dior
ball gowns yeah you say that because our
generation
and when i say our generation i'm
speaking about millennials right older a
bit younger sure
um because we didn't grow up with this
with culture
telling us that men should be women and
women should be men actually that was
some this this is a new crazy that the
left has unleashed
um really has unleashed it i would say
over the last five years now where
they're kind of harping
on these kids to understand that gender
is made up um
and you know your kid i mean who's the
chick that's always naked on instagram
emma rota
rockowski rojokowski or something yeah
yeah she's always naked always says it's
a new reason
you know um naked today from this issue
that's what we call it
in america by the way she does have a
nice body i wish she would just be like
i'm naked because i have a nice body and
stop pretending i have some social
issues but whatever so she's pregnant
and the first thing she does is issues a
long statement saying
that she's going to be part of the
parents that raise their kid
um to have no gender and wait for their
kid to tell her when she's 18
um what gender it is by the way there's
no way at 18
that that that daughter or son is still
speaking emily ryankowski
she better get that she better get that
she better get that sooner
it is weird like we saw that you you you
i think it's a you
you tina you you tell it what is the
church unitarian
the unitarian video where they bring up
the young kid it was on twitter who's
like two
and they're like hey uh tell everyone
you're
transgender it was weird it was all the
creepy elements of religion yeah it's
weird it's just weird yeah it's weird
and it is because of
now we're sort of treading towards this
atheist society that they're looking for
new forms of religion these are new
types of cults
um that are happening let the left has
become a cult where they just want to
undo things that we didn't have a
problem with
at no point when i was growing up as a
little girl was i like man i really wish
i could go into the guy's bathroom it's
just not fair or like you know i really
wish
like um i could just act like a boy and
all of a sudden i never had those
feelings i was a tomboy
for a period of time but my mother never
said well this must mean that you
are deep down inside a boy and thank god
she didn't because i grew out of it when
i went through puberty and suddenly i
thought that the guys were
not cool but cute right um so i mean in
terms of the hairy southern i said
something that everyone
reasonably should have agreed with he
did he's not masculine when he's wearing
a dress
and you have to pay attention to those
trends because whatever they're putting
on the cover of vogue
that's what's around the cup that's
what's around the corner that's what's
around the corner culturally um and i'm
just staunchly against
you know this trans agenda as i call it
of course if you're a trans person
you're suffering from gender dysphoria
which is a real issue right um you know
then you know
you should be afforded every protection
you should never be attacked um
but no i'm always i'm always for maximum
freedom uh
i think maximum freedom too much of
progressivism now seems to be about
reducing the freedom of others right it
seems to be about
corralling people and going you need to
think like i do
you need to believe this or you are a
problem
homophobic like you know and that that's
what i got for saying that he was not
masculine in a dress
um you know i got called a transphobe
like i'm not
afraid phobia means a fear of i'm not
afraid of men in dresses
right i'm stating my opinion that why
can't we just have normal why can't we
just see a nuclear family
on the cover of any of these magazines
they're just trying to get freakier and
freakier and freakier
um and i think that there is a
difference between diversity and
perversity and novel left is turning
trending towards perversity
it's not about being diverse about being
how perverse can you get
um and i'm just not for it so i say what
i say and that's that it's tough to be a
man isn't it
tough to be a guy very but you got to do
it or you don't i don't care
doesn't matter to me what you do but if
you're going to do it bespoke post has a
new box of
awesome you get everything styling
grooming goods
bar wear cooking tools outdoor gear make
your real manger
it's important to have all of the things
you need to be a man in a box
and have that box shipped to you by
bespoke
post i'll tell you right now take the
quiz at box of awesome dot com your
answers will help them pick
the right box of awesome for you they
release new boxes every month
across a ton of different categories
it's free to sign up and you can skip a
month or cancel anytime
each box is only 45 and it's got 70
worth of gear inside i mean really
personal and grooming
bar where cooking tools outdoor gear
it's a really cool way
to get a bunch of different things that
you need in a box
for 45 you could get a box a month if
you want of just cool stuff
i love gadgets and things and fun yeah
they give you something you open the bag
you get it you go whoa
it you're shaving with it and then look
at this a martini
shaker whatever and it's you know what i
mean and then you go oh look and
this is a knife for the for oh i scare
the bear
when i'm camping i bring the knife out
and then the bear goes oh
not not today i'll go kill that family
or i don't know
but what i'm saying is that you get a
lot of stuff
in the box of awesome you got a lot of
stuff
it's important that it comes in a box
whether it's gear to upgrade your autumn
craft beers or
cody threads or cozy threads for when
the temperature dips
how about that you get a box come in and
you get a little cozy thread
a little uh sweater
how great would it be get it you get a
shaver a sweater
some gear to upgrade your craft beers
and outdoor gear maybe a little uh tent
it's nice there's younger people
listening to this show than i thought
some of you you wanna you wanna be a man
and grow into being a man
this is this is worth all the ten jordan
peterson books
this is real [ __ ] stuff right i'll tell
you to slay the dragon and bring the
goal back to the village you don't even
have to spend the money
i'll tell you that i'll tell you gotta
go on the archetypical heroes journey
this you get a box you get a maybe a
shaver
and a knife yeah something outdoors
outdoor i'm not i'm not an outdoorsman
no you could go off the grid if you got
one of these boxes
you could leave society
with one of these boxes from bespoke
post
but still like craft beer yeah like
leave
and go i don't like stop lights driver's
licenses
i don't enjoy the collective don't like
it not for me but i like craft beer
and i like some some cozy threads for
when it gets
cool i'm telling you right now box of
awesome.com you have nothing to lose a
great way to support
our show enter the code tim dillon at
checkout box of awesome.com
enter the code tim dillon at checkout
for 20 off
your first box see what's in the box
see what's in the box yeah what do you
have to lose
this is a great gift for the holidays
i get nothing for the holidays cake some
requests from him
i have this can i have that i have money
i have this my wife wants a lexus
you know everybody's but what i want
is to get something i want a box of
awesome
go to box of awesome dot com enter the
code tim dylan check out box of awesome
dot com code tim dillon for 20
off your first box ridge wallet yum
ridge wallet sponsors the show they've
done so for a very long time it's a
minimal front pocket wallet
it's designed to streamline what you
carry every day it's got thirty thousand
five star reviews it's a better way to
carry your cash and cards do you have a
ridge wallet yes i do
please take it out hold on i'm glad you
prepared
for this huh jesus christ
the ridge wallet you gotta walk across
the frame like that
i can't really go around yeah
everybody's gonna eat the email i'm
going he abuses you
that's not right you shouldn't take care
you shouldn't take constructive
criticism
look at this here it is folks is there
anything easier to sanitize than the
ridge wallet
you take a little sanitizer you put it
in your hand and you sanitize your
entire
wallet okay that is huge right now
because of the bubonic plague ridge
is a titanium wallet it's metal
it's got this little band here you could
fit some a few cards some cash but what
it forces you to do is go what really
matters what do i really need
this is easy this does not bulge so
nobody's going to see it and go let's
kill that person let's rob them
um basically it is
a it's an organizer it
forces you to organize your entire life
it's
great it is really great you have this
little clip right here
you know yeah that one has the band it
has a big clip if you want to do a clip
this is a band this is easy it is easy
and you it's a front pocket wallet you
put it right in your front pocket it's
not a big deal
it's tough it's durable i mean it's
everything you could want from a wallet
you get 10
off free worldwide shipping and returns
by going to ridge.com tim that's 10
by going to ridge.com
tim and if you use the code tim in
description so you have to use the code
tim description and you get this what
kind is this which one did you get
that is the i think that's a titanium
one i got yeah i think that's a titanium
one too
i like it man i dig it and you got more
than enough room here for for the things
you really need you got a few cards in
here
you know you could throw some you could
throw a little cash easy
fold a little cash easy this is the move
the ridge wallet
the official wallet of podcasting in
america really
thank you now you recently joined daily
wire
i did you're on daily wire that's very
exciting now why
did you just cause now you and ben
shapiro have kind of you're a little bit
of a team
in a way not a team but you're on the
bench bureau team
right now you guys are kind of different
ideologically right i mean you're very
similar in many ways but like
i would say he's more maybe a kind of an
old-school conservative and i think
you're more of a
kind of a nationalist if if that's right
am i wrong there
i we do have differences um uh without
characterizing it i would say you're
absolutely right you're hitting at we
are stylistically different
right um and we have had we've bought
heads in the past
uh ben and i and now what so what about
that move was the move you just said i'm
gonna do it
i think it's the right i think what the
daily wire invites
and and people may not realize it now is
that there are people that
completely disagree with daily wire
michael knowles and i actually tend to
agree on stuff
uh more often than not and him and ben
shapiro disagree on a lot of things and
michael
knowles has been a part of the daily
wire team for a very long time so i
think that they're
you know they are smart enough to
realize that they're not trying to
inspire group things they're trying to
you know lift different voices um and
sort of
take over if you will like you know
become an alternative
uh to the left and everything that we
see on tv is always a leftist
perspective
um so we ben and i will still disagree
on certain people
different ideas um but we do so you know
and are able to make fun of one another
and not take it too seriously
yeah and he has a pretty good sense of
humor too i think for the most part i
see him he has a pretty good sense of
humor he's not
now about covert you know i just have my
producer here and i just ordered two
cova tests you know we have no symptoms
we're not sick
but i'm spending about six hundred
dollars to have a guy come in here
we do this a lot like they talk about
canceling student loan debt i want them
to cancel the thousands of dollars i've
spent
on cova tests where i don't even know if
they're accurate no one really knits all
the guessing game
and then the doctor comes over they
barely they don't have a mask i'm like
you're not afraid
so now kofi kova's clearly real it's
clearly a problem
but you have i don't know that i agree
with you here but you make kind of a
compelling case
that this is part of something larger
that the the in that it's been inflated
to a degree
um now and and how would you say that
because i was listening to you you did a
live stream i think last week where you
said
i have been calling out how kova is
going to be used
um uh to to to get donald trump out of
office for a while you've been calling
it out probably since february
that's right and and but it's happening
all over the world
and it is something that's an actual
disease and it can be quite devastating
but what do you think has been done
on the left uh in your estimation
to inflame the situation or to
uh you know make it uh um a catalyst to
remove trump
well first and foremost kovid was never
going to kill millions and millions of
americans that was always a lie
um it was about uh basically
transforming america a free society into
a totalitarian state
um you know going into this year trump
had a roaring economy and there used to
be that expression
it's the economy stupid guarantees you a
second year um
we did not have a mail-in ballot system
which is
the most fraudulent susceptible system
that you could possibly have in terms of
voting
um implementing that entire system
virtually overnight in all 50 states and
just going there's no way there's going
to be any fraud
um so i was calling that out which seems
obvious so its economy got crashed
you change the entire way that america
votes which allows for more fraud
um and at the same time you're crashing
american businesses when we know that
china was very close to
i mean essentially what china has been
trying to do for those of us you know
who study
um foreign policy has been taking you
know the belt and road initiative
getting
all of the world to turn to china um as
the world leader and that's very much
happening right now i mean china despite
implementing
um genocide on the muslims somehow has a
seat
on the humanitarian board at the u.n
which makes entirely no sense
uh china was able a country of 1.3
billion people
right i've been to china everyone's like
this at all times
was able to knock out the coronavirus
and reopen everyone's businesses in two
weeks
um and we just can't figure it out in
the west they can't figure it out
anywhere
and our our infection rates first they
were playing around with the death rates
and and we had the censorship from the
tech uh
people were coming out and saying yes um
my father died of cancer and cobit 19 is
on his death certificate because in
post-mortem testing which has never been
done
they're looking for a strand of this
virus which the majority of people who
get it are asymptomatic i mean i've
probably had coba 10 times i've declined
to wear a mask
i've traveled to at least four countries
um you know right at the height of it
i've had and i say this in my act i've i
believe i've had cover for 10 years
yeah i make everything so this is the
big deadly virus
guys and by the way at his thing about
the lab if they actually thought that it
was a big deadly virus we were all going
to die
they'd be encouraging trump rallies they
hate trump supporters right they'd be
like yes
all of you go into a pit and then we
expect all of you to die
i hosted events with thousands of people
they were sanctioning protests but then
saying
so i mean it was just the entire
mainstream millionaire made entirely no
sense but they wanted us to be home
they want us to be on our cell phones
they want us to be essentially just
paying attention to them
and the psychological game of it the
death ticker that was the thing that i
was like this
is like next level creepy stuff because
no matter what you have going on in
america you have
never seen a death ticker you've never
seen the news tell you every time
somebody dies of something
how they even were able to do that
considering your health records are
private yet they were somehow
telling you how many people were dying
of coping 19 was completely bizarre
if there was a death ticker to tell you
every time somebody died in a car
accident you'd never get in your car
because it creates psychological trauma
and that's what they were trying to do
psychologically traumatize people
to fundamentally change the way that we
act every single day
um and it happened people bought into it
i mean i just was at the grocery store
and a woman came up to me and she just
said to me excuse me
uh you're pregnant i want to let you
know if your mask is not over your nose
like
you're going to catch this thing
ironically you know me i love whole
foods
um and i turned to her and i said i
i don't care if i get chronovirus and
what is wrong with you what weird like
i'm a young springy 31 year old woman if
i get coronavirus i promise you it's not
going to be anywhere near as bad as the
flu
i had two years ago um which wiped me
completely on my butt and we've never
had a flu ticker we've never had anybody
talking about
flu is more likely to kill children we
never made children wear masks during
flu season i just saw kids
more likely i just i rented a house in
uh in california and i'm and i'm
we're driving to get breakfast and uh me
and my producer and we see
high school kids running in masks and it
was very odd like they're at
gym and they're running outside in masks
that's when i go
this doesn't make any sense i understand
you're in a crowded place you want to
wear a mask whatever
but running outside a mask it does feel
cultish and weird yeah
it's just weird especially because the
statistics are in the kids are more
likely to die of the flu so why was
why weren't we masking these children
every flu season
and it's because it's all about the
psychological trauma of seeing a child
in a mask and
and we're all in this together all of
this like commie type rhetoric we're all
in this together
it's your quota of the night it's your
global family now don't have
thanksgiving with your family
we're all a part of a global family i'm
like i don't care
you could say something to me a million
times i am a pretty um strong-headed
bull minded i'm going to be with my
family i'm not going to mask my family
in fact i have a strict
no mask policy in my home so i respect
how you want to live you know run your
home
you're not allowed to wear a mask in
mine um and that's just my i'm my kid's
gonna grow like a normal kid he's gonna
breathe
um so if you have an issue with that and
uh you can hate candace
do you think do you think there's any
chance that trump
pulls this out i do one hundred percent
really yeah yeah i think the supreme
court
the supreme court has i have been
talking about the fact that this
election was going to end up in the
supreme court since february
you can go back and watch my um um my
interview with the daily caller it might
have been early march
um and i have said this is this is the
most rigged election just looking ahead
at what was down the pipeline in terms
of what we were how we were
fundamentally transforming our society
i expected there to be a lot of fraud um
and i expected that trump would appeal
to the supreme court
um so at the end of the day this is
going to come down to whether or not
they are able
to prove and not just prove but be able
to communicate what they are saying
about the fraud
um i am sorry i don't care if you're on
the left if you're on the right
if you believe that joe biden secured
the most votes
like that that there was more energy for
joe biden than there was
for barack obama in 2008 you're kidding
yourself well right
wouldn't the argument be that it was an
anti-trump vote what nobody was excited
about biden but they were it
it wasn't an anti-trump vote you know we
know that 30 percent of people didn't
even bother voting
right so despite the fact that we are
completely submerged in politics
not all of america is right so for me
it's every day is day in and day out but
i also
know that my cousins that live in the
projects couldn't give us stuff
about anything that i do my cousins
literally i went to eat with one of my
cousins um
her name's mia and i'm like we i was
talking about brexit and she was like
what's brexit i want to hang out with
her i want to hang out with her
i'm sitting in l.a everybody talking
about politics i want to go hang out
with your cousins for the projects
tomorrow
and i said i said there i said mia it's
you know the brits left the european
union and she goes
what's the european union and i was like
i love you yeah i love her too
i love her too by the way i want to go
hang out with her do you do you
what explains and i mean you have a huge
part of this i think i tweeted that i
said candace oh it's a huge
thing now the black conservative
movement is very no it's not covered by
the media at all
and you're the biggest voice in it but
there's tons of people out there coleman
hughes whatever it is a lot of different
people
and the media ignores this like it's not
happening
and some of the most interesting
conversations
that are happening online are are
black conservatives that are talking
about
uh american policy and and and
disagreeing and
and and it's very very interesting trump
made gains
with minority voters you know what do
you think
explains that because we've had the most
strenuous year
for race relations probably in in in
that i can remember
and donald trump is very volatile figure
gains
with minority voters what would you
attribute that to
people like me independent voices uh
people are not
buying it anymore and and goes back to
what we talked about earlier the fatigue
of victimhood i mean if if you weren't
tired of being just black this year
when everything oh you're struggling you
know you're just being black i mean
at a certain point i kept saying black
america's gonna wake up to this game you
can't just keep doing this every four
years and popping around and then black
lives matter black lives matter
disappearing like a magic act and then
jumping back in you know for the next
election cycle
eventually black people are going to get
smart um and and that's what's happening
you know we're having conversations we
have our own platforms this is the
reason why the left is ignoring us but
at the same time pushing for social
media censorship
because it's problematic when people
like canis owens can gain you know
millions and millions
of followers and you know they are no
longer relying on the mainstream
narrative
about race right they have another
option and that option sounds a lot
better than waking up every day
and being miserable just because of the
color of your skin and seeing yourself
as a victim like it's
it just feels better i have a better
product right you get to go out and be
happy and live your life
you can do anything you want because
this is the greatest country in the
world
versus you are a victim permanently a
victim your life is going to suck
forever because you were born with brown
skin
but i think it's i i think it would be
fair to say
that black people face a different set
of challenges than white people
they they you know in many in many cases
right
and that specifically well i think that
if you look at where i grew up i grew up
in long island and long island a lot of
my friends were able to
inherit homes because their parents got
loans
after world war ii or their grandparents
got loans after world war ii
to buy these houses and they created the
suburbs i think a lot of black people
were excluded
not only from those loans but also from
like those communities like realtors
that
showed black people houses would be
threatened and it was like
so the suburbs and the house which
seemed like the the engine of wealth for
a lot of middle class families right
building equity in something
ownership if black people were excluded
from that so i feel like
there is a little bit of catch-up being
played certainly
because that doesn't explain or account
for the reason that black americans
during my grandfather's time did better
than black americans during my father's
time
so that defeats your entire argument
right well it was ownership
so what happened from you know the 1950s
through to the 1970s that black
americans became
more impoverished you know owned less
homes
and became more reliant upon the
government structure and the truth is
is we married the government welfare and
now whether you want to argue whether or
not that was strategic and whether it's
the fault of the government and lyndon
baines johnson
uh you know for opposing the great
society act which is what married black
women to the government
that's an argument you can have but you
can't say it's because there's this
long-standing
black american just couldn't break away
if you look at the 100 years following
slavery
black americans did well the fact that
black americans performed better
economically under jim crow
laws than they are doing today you just
cannot point
to a systemic racism it has to do with
choices
the choices that we made to marry the
government and the fact that we cannot
out-think this government structure that
you know black americans still believe
in the victimhood and will take the
handouts that black americans will take
to the streets and demand
you know aoc right now is saying we need
to make sure you know black and brown
people the government pays them to stay
home
well hello welfare policies that you
know were the first in their crippled
black america in the first place
that they're being reintroduced right
now under coven 19.
so i always see right now we have a
choice right now if we're going to give
another
100 years to black poverty by all the
saying yes to more government handouts
we don't need government handouts that's
the biggest issue is
more and more and more from the
government the government is not our
parent it's not our mother it's not our
father
it was an attack on the black family um
but if we don't wake up to that we're
never going to get ahead
black people make the worst decisions
out of every
um out of every group in america and and
you can compare us to who
who is the most successful group in
america it's not white americans so
your argument about you know white
america is this is it asians
it's asia i forget who it is
yeah so nobody wants to talk about
asians because it you know it defeats
all the arguments well why people had it
easier
because no one's going to say asian
people during world war ii were japanese
people were internment camps
right well that should be the title
right about white americans today
the title of your next book should be
nobody wants to talk about asians can't
buy candace house i know i exactly
yeah i do understand but as as a white
person i always say to myself i was a
druggie i drove around
i did not get pulled over nearly as much
as my black friends
i feel like they 100
are more likely to get pulled over and
more likely to go to jail
and we're doing a lot of the same things
right i was uh
you know irresponsible reckless human
being
and i just feel like i maybe had i
definitely had
certain advantages that put me in a
better position
versus a kid you know just the idea that
i had money for a lawyer so if like
if there's a black kid who got caught
smoking uh blunt and went to jail
um and he went to jail and my parents
could maybe get me a lawyer to get me
out of it
that to me is it's easier being white
than if that's the
right but here's what's wrong you just
brought up a good point and then you
racialized it
okay rich people yes yes economic
privilege is a real thing it didn't
happen because
you're white right so it didn't matter
if you think that puff daddy's son
is not going to be better off being
pulled off if he has pot
right than some poor white kid you're
wrong but you've accepted the argument
that because of the color of your skin
not because of your economic
circumstances
right because of your economic
circumstances oprah winfrey doesn't have
any offspring but i'll guarantee you
that if they ever got into trouble
they'd be able to get out malia and
sasha obama who we know like to smoke
pot good you know
good for them they're you know they're
enjoying their uh teenage years
right they are not going to go through
the same things that a poor white trash
kid is going through
stop racializing people have more
privilege
do you think that's common sense do you
think we should legalize
weed so that we don't have this crazy
drug war that's putting people in jail
no i mean listen i i i i have to think
through those arguments more because i
do think
that first and foremost i i think
conservatives that pretend like pot is
the worst thing in the entire world
are just completely crazy and out of
control um but
the issue is the slippery slope argument
and we know that's real because right
now in california what are they doing
trying to
um with a heroin and methamphetamine
they're trying to make it so you just
get a ticket and keep going so
the problem with the left is that you
never just stop at one thing you're not
like okay you legalize pot and they're
going to be done
right they're like already in california
pushing for decriminalizing
methamphetamine heroin
and and this is now an argument that we
have to fight so it's hard to find what
the right answer is
when you know that it's it's never
enough to do one thing meaning
a couple years ago it was all about just
gay marriage just gay marriage
i mean the second the supreme court
passed gay marriage we were on trans
rights and we it's been
shoved down our throat uh and now we're
at kids picking their gender and
bathroom signs need to all
to be all inclusive and men name tampons
in their restroom
so i mean i i don't know where i stand
on it completely because i understand
but isn't there a little bit of
a you know listen slippery slope
argument certainly makes a lot of sense
but isn't there so much pain happening
because
of non-violent drug offenders being in
jail for so long it's disproportionately
affected
people that are as you said economically
disenfranchised lots of them happen to
be black and hispanic
i just feel like there's so much pain
there's so many real world consequences
to that particular law that we should
especially when
it is legal yeah it is legal in certain
parts of the country
people are becoming millionaires yeah
okay so criminalizing is different than
saying
making it legal um and and i agree with
you i think we spend a lot of time
uh you know the idea of anyone being in
prison for smoking pot is just
ridiculous
no where are you where are you are you
strictly pro-life
no abortion no matter what see i don't
know we don't know where candace owens
feels about every single issue we don't
are you like 100 never can have an
abortion or is there any gray area with
you
the problem is that there's no gray area
with the left right so
i'm pro-life i'm unapologetically
pro-life because i understand now as
someone who used to be pro-choice
um just how brainwashed you are as a
young girl in school about abortion
i mean until i was 25 i thought it was
just a clump of cells
which is crazy i mean that's just so
that's fundamentally teaching you
um that that abortion is birth control
um
and that you it is the responsible thing
for you
to you know kill your child and when you
look when i actually understood the
history of abortion and studied margaret
sanger
and understood that it was actually a
eugenicist movement
um where people were trying to get rid
of black people having any offspring
and we look at the numbers and you
realize that it is black americans that
are giving
disproportionately it uh the black
population would be double today if it
wasn't for abortion that's a scary thing
to even say
and that these clinics are being put
strategically in black and hispanic
neighborhoods
um you know i haven't i have an issue
with what abortion was designed to do
and the fact that it's been largely
successful
um you know by margaret sanger but you
know through and through
is as an american success story you know
she wanted to make sure people
um that were black and brown um as well
as immigrants from
eastern europe uh were not able to have
any offspring so i have an issue because
i'm educated about it
um and i think the thing that bothers me
so much is i know that the other
argument is well
all of these people having kids unless
you're going to take care of their kids
you know
first and foremost it it makes it seem
like people cannot be responsible at all
you remove responsibility from the
person and we know the majority of
people
are not getting rapes that extreme
argument of like well you know what if
you're raped
um and then you get pregnant and now
you're forced to have this killer's kid
the left has to rely on that because the
majority of the time you know it's not
rape
it's just people being irresponsible and
then deciding what they want to get
there's a lot of people that are like
okay we don't want abortion and we
because i
understand pro-life people i'm
pro-choice because i don't want to tell
somebody else that may have had an
experience whether it's rape or not that
they don't want to carry a child to term
i don't necessarily think it's my
position to tell them that they have to
do that
but then then there are people that go
on the right they go no contraception no
plan b
nothing nothing i don't believe in that
okay you need so there needs to be some
yeah
you know i don't like late term abortion
i think it's but
at the end of the day i i feel like you
know
there seems to just be a
you know like unwillingness
to imagine that we're living in a
society where people do have
other moral codes so not everyone's
gonna have the moral code that you do
not everyone's gonna have the moral code
that whatever that i may or
at the end of the day it's like i think
that we need to figure out a way
to exist in a society where people can
have different beliefs and as long as
they're not infringing on your ability
to live happily then they can kind of
live as long as they're not
compelling you you know
candace you froze candace we lost you
sorry i just do not accept you talking
about abortion when i'm eight months
pregnant
yeah i was just i was just about to say
i said i i
you know it's just one of those problems
recently we moved our show to cia.gov
and they promised that there would be
nothing that they would do
but they said we're going to leave the
show as is cia.gov is where you can find
the tim dillon show now
but that's my thing it's like we're all
you know we're all living in a society
everyone's gonna believe different
things
and i think that we should all try to we
should try to respect each other i know
that that seems like a crazy statement
but
i i feel like you know people shouldn't
um infringe on each other's freedoms if
at all possible unless it's something
absurd
so let me let me just say something to
you and i'm going to bring up what i
said earlier to you so i said earlier to
you that
you know the stuff about women being men
it wasn't the thing that they pushed
when we were in school
right um and that's the thing now the
younger generation is grappling with
they're being told women can be men men
can be women
well our generation was actually what
was pushed upon us was sexual freedom
right so if you're a millennial the
whole concept it's just a clump of cells
everybody's having sex all of this stuff
was basically shut down our throat
generation before didn't get that
right so you your perspective on
abortion is actually you being a product
of your own generation
and the way that i learned about this
and it's a really good book written by
thomas soule called inside
inside the education system the dog dog
mobilize the deception he talks about
this sounds like a fun read like a light
fun read
i mean i i love thomas soul but he talks
about this push
for you know sexual freedom and
everybody's doing it and like
what is it aren't we all products of our
generation like isn't the idea that
you've my me being okay with you voting
means i'm a product of my generation
too right yeah yeah you know there's
there's always some good things and
what i'm saying is that your perspective
and what was my perspective so i'm not
even calling you out on it i agreed with
you
right now it's it's what they
there's something that they give to
every generation and we became the like
yeah sex it's whatever
it's a woman's body my body my choice i
mean that was the poison that was taught
to us and that i i've kind of reversed
that
with the exception that i don't now i'm
also not the person that goes around a
woman got an abortion and calls her
a baby killer or believe it i don't
believe that's helpful dialogue
um i believe that everyone can be
educated and you can decide to become
educated
later about something like i did uh
without being vicious towards people
that have made different decisions in
their life
um with the information that they had
available at that time sheath underwear
is great it's great as
underwear it's great as a bathing suit
the guy who uh run sheath underwear is a
big fan of mine he's a huge fan of
comedy he's a big supporter of comedy
and podcasters it's really really good
sheath underwear dot com go check it out
if you use tim
30 you save 30 till christmas
sheath is amazing i really really like
it and i'm not just saying that they
send me
i got a care package of it today it's
perfect it's great if you're an
athlete it's great if you're a not an
athlete it's great if you're a swimmer
it's great if you don't swim it's great
if you sweat a lot it's great if you
don't sweat a lot it's fine it has like
a
pouch to keep your junk all you know
nice and perky and
you know it really it um it stops
chafing it stops
all the uncomfortable stuff that you
know you run into with underwear
uh sheath underwear really eliminates
all of that
and it's it's great it comes in some
cool styles it's fun
um you know it's really all i wear now
in terms of underwear really is the best
they're the best
underwear company and i'm i'm really
happy that they sponsor the show and
then i actually
like the product you wear it too yes i
do yeah i mean that's a real
you know testament to it is that both of
us wear it
we actually do we actually actually do
wear it
ben wears women's panties and i had to
get him
to eventually start trying sheath
underwear
but he wears thongs like thongs that
stick out of his genes to a point where
it's kind of like
it's odd but that's part of what happens
when you raise
deeply christian you have to act out in
these interesting ways
and ben wears kind of like leopard
thongs and black thought really like
stripper thongs yeah yeah
and just just a g-string jammed up his
ass but then we said why don't you try
sheath and since then he's been wearing
sheath
love it and it's been you know a really
good
thing for him you know and we really
appreciate that because he just wore
g-strings and it was like odd
but i support my friends and even him
who's he's more of an acquaintance
really
but i support him in whatever he does
you know but
so if you go to sheath underwear dot com
it's pretty simple folks go to sheath
underwear dot com do some research the
inventor robert
patron what's his name the inventor
robert patron check the story it's
interesting and even somewhat inspiring
yeah
it's an inspiring story of the [ __ ] can
you get up the story the sheath
underwear guy
by the way this better be [ __ ]
inspiring i'll take back everything i
said but i do like the underwear but
robert patron sheath underwear i mean
what's the story here
what's the inspiring story what is the
inspiring story i'm very curious now as
to what they are linked
why where is what is the inspiring story
for sheath underwear
it's like robert spent 10 years as a
neo-nazi in a militia and then he
decided
that it was time to make underwear
because he realized he didn't really
hate jews he just hated chafing
where's his story oh our story here our
story here we go
here we go oh it's the vet he's a
veteran
that's right this is what it is robert
patton robert patton he's a veteran he
was serving our country overseas in the
scorching heat of the iraqi desert
he was a guard at a prison called abu
ghraib
which they then closed robert
was the leash specialist at abu ghraib i
don't know what that means
he tended to the dogs he was the german
shepherd trainer and
leash specialist at abu ghraib
prison and then i think he went to work
at a restaurant called
guantanamo bay which was probably a
seafood restaurant
and he was in charge of the water i
guess he was a bus boys who did the
water
at guantanamo bay and he did the leashes
and the dogs
at abu ghraib which is probably what i i
think what they were doing is they were
uh giving dogs to the iraqi children and
he was in charge of leashing the dog
and then giving the puppies to the
families that's nice
so it is an inspiring story hey sheath
underwear.com
sheath underwear is that am i saying
that right can you get the thing up
please
sheath underwear dot com
tim30 you save 30 till christmas
if you're very good looking and you want
to take a photo of yourself in the
sheath and you have a nice bulge
i'll repost it but it you better be very
good-looking
six-pack big bulge and we'll put it
right on the instagram
trying to get you some followers try to
get your only fan some traction
sheath underwear dot com promo code
tim30
if you're bald your life is over not
guys like joe rogan but they have a
better work ethic than you and more
money
you you cannot go bald unless you're
bald or ready but if you're not bold
already and you
are starting to lose your hair you got
to use keeps keeps helps you
keep the hair that you have right now
they offer generic versions of the only
two fda approved hair loss products out
there
okay this is about preventing the hair
loss that's taking place
naturally on your head it's not about
getting a wig
it is not about uh regrowing hair it's
about keeping what you got
it's so important they started about ten
dollars a month for a limited time you
can get your first month free
nobody wants to go bald nobody wants
that weird
male pattern baldness reseeding
hairlines things like that
what keeps allows you to do is take a
simple pill
that will prevent you from losing hair
it'll stop your hair loss right in its
tracks
okay it's so important much of our
identity is wrapped up in our hair
from how it feels after getting a fresh
cut to the way it's perfectly styled
before going out
that's why when we get into our 20s and
30s and start noticing the first signs
of hair loss
it feels like panic time but let's face
it
no guy is ever ready to go bald so
thankfully there's keeps
the simple and easy way to keep
your hair ben didn't use keeps he's got
a wig
this is a wig this is not his natural
hair
it is hair that has been surgically
welded to his head
it's disgusting but with keeps you don't
have to do
that okay we got a special offer take
action and prevent hair loss
keeps.com tim dillon to receive your
first month of treatment for free
that's keeps.com tim dillon
k-e-e-p-s dot com
k-e-e-p-s dot com to keep
your hair don't you wanna do it
i'm telling you right now uh it's so
important do we have a promo
code yeah just keeps.com tim dillon
slash tim dillon folks and you will
he'll keep your hair
uh and and this is important for
everybody and women right no
yeah of course yeah women men you gotta
keep the hair
thank you now in terms of the police
because there does seem to be an issue
here with the police and the black
community this is
from what i've casually observed how
would you
address this issue yeah uh as somebody
that we make candace owns president
tomorrow
uh what do we do do we demilitarize the
police do we de-incentivize
no we don't well isn't there a way to
demilitarize our kids
i'm not saying defund them but do do we
need
for the police to be like stormtroopers
running around the country
kicking down doors because somebody
might be smoking a joint there's got to
be a way
to reign the police in a little bit no
let's be clear the police are not
kicking down your door because you're
smoking a joint okay so that is like
that's like that's like left is a
fantasy land like are you smoking good
joy and the police always just kick down
the door
and because they're just like military
right now like come on that's ridiculous
like
maybe you're a drug dealer and you
happen to be smoking a joint and the
police came at that moment but let's
let's be real about that secondly i have
this crazy i'm trying
i'm trying i'm just smoking a joy man i
just came
in here guns are waving um but
what i will say i'm a big believer
in teaching your kids to respect police
officers so
somebody can point to me to um the case
this year
where the person who we saw being you
know
aggressively pursued by the police was
listening to the police officers
um instructions then i would say okay
maybe we do have an issue with police
officers
every single case that is brought to the
public forefront the thing that never
gets discussed is
why couldn't this person listen to
police orders and i mean we're not
talking about
like the police snapped on the i'm
talking the police officer is saying
18 20 30 times giving them an
instruction and they don't do it
and they keep coming towards the police
officer a police officer's life needs to
be protected too
um and these people are crazy what we
saw in philadelphia with that guy walter
wallace
wielding a knife i mean and and still
black lives matter protested and rioted
and looted
and because he was shot and killed as he
should have been shot and killed because
he tried to kill police officers
um the problem is that we have arrived
suddenly into a society where people do
not believe
that they have to respect adults period
and this is what happens when you have
an entire generation of people who have
grown up
without fathers in the home you know the
idea of listening to any type of
authority feels to them to be
like an assault why should i have to
listen to a police officer why should i
listen to my teacher
why should i listen to my guidance
counselor we have an authority issue
in this country in terms of having basic
respect and it's not a hard request when
a police officer pulls you over
i've been pulled over i listen to his
instructions that's the first thing
right now you have parents teaching
people you don't have to listen to
police officers instructions
if you are black but when we look at it
it's going to lead
to more black death when we look at a
lot of these videos we see
incidences where police seem to be using
excessive force
right now the most extreme example is
george floyd who lost his life but then
there's other
examples where we look at the videos and
we go wait a minute what in god's name
is happening
why are the cops doing this why are they
sitting on a guy
why are they cutting off his airway like
can't
shouldn't cops be trained to
basically get someone in cuffs and then
put them in a police car
and not use a lot of these techniques
that they're using whether it's a
chokehold or something where
you can do serious damage to somebody
wouldn't that be good to kind of
do more training i mean more training is
not a bad idea right for the police
saying when is it one is a cop done a
choke hold on somebody without asking
them to first abide by basic
instructions and let's use george floyd
at his example
because they refuse to release the full
tape in its entirety until it leaked to
daily mail
you know some eight months after the
riots had stopped right
he was asked to get in the vehicle he
was already in cops and was asked to get
the vehicle he resisted
getting in the vehicle as he was
standing he was already cupped said he
was claustrophobic and didn't want to
get in the vehicle and asked to be put
on the ground
right this is after he had they had
gotten him from a car so we knew he
wasn't claustrophobic when he was in the
car trying to get rid of his fentanyl
right then they try to put him in the
police cruiser and he starts saying i
can't get in there i'm claustrophobic
saying i can't breathe as he's standing
up right so
once again we have a situation where
we're so keen
to say what police officers could have
done differently what can human beings
you know people that are not police
officers do follow basic instructions oh
we got to imagine that the job
they're interested to put you in a
chokehold right but
the job of a cop is you're dealing with
people when they're not at their best
right now i've
people that i know that are cops that
tell me our job is we're
if we're at a situation you're already
dealing with somebody that's not at
their best they might be drunk
they might be on drugs they're they're
basically this is not the best moment of
their day
and i just think that it can't be like
hey abide by me or the immediate next
step is chokehold there does have to be
some value in de-escalation training or
we cannot stand on someone's head i'm
sure you agree with the george floyd you
know that
like what they did to george floyd was
was murder it was crazy i agree with
that and i've said it over and over
again that i didn't have that situation
even though i do feel it's important to
point out that george floyd by his you
know
um according to his death record he did
not die from a chokehold he died from a
fentanyl overdose
i'm sure the chokehold didn't help i'm
i'm sure it didn't help but
he he he was not restrained in a way
that stopped his breathing
media misrepresentation that should be
clarified right um but regardless
if i don't think a police officer should
be on anybody's neck for nine for nine
minutes
right um and so i will agree with you on
that assessment but i what i also i'm
disagreeing with you on
um is the idea that this is the standard
across police officers you know what i
mean i mean millions and millions of
arrests every single year
and we're talking about 20 of them um
that go wrong
all right and nine black men where the
situation went wrong
this year down from when obama was in
office so we're hyper focusing on an
issue
um nine arrests that went wrong in all
of
in all of 2019 despite 2020 despite all
of these arrests
um and why are we doing that human
beings are not perfectable so you're
never going to be able to beat that
amazing number of nine going wrong
right but and this is the reason why we
know the names of every single black
person
that has ended in an unfortunate
circumstance with police officers
because it doesn't happen often
so we're able to know every single one
of their names and um you know again i
believe in personal responsibility and
accountability
i think police officers are treated
horribly uh more often than the other
way around and and the
data and statistics back up my point
police officers are killed by
black men 18 and a half times more than
black men are killed by police officers
so you're now you're you're you're
putting the honest on police officers to
be even nicer even though they're 18 and
a half times more likely to end up dead
than the other than the other way around
um no it doesn't so it's a dangerous job
it's a dangerous job and it's one of
those jobs where
i think like a nurse like i joke around
about nurses now that are yelling and
screaming on facebook about how tough
their job
is i get it it's a tough job but when
you were a nurse you also signed up for
the idea that sick people were going to
come into hospitals this is part of what
you signed up for so i just feel like
with cops like they
signed up for a job that was potentially
deadly it was very dangerous
and they are not the ones complaining
and protesting right all right
yeah she's you know but but listen
sometimes they complain when you do
when you ask them uh to you know
potentially
you know you know like take a look at
their
behavior or their culpability i've heard
cops just like
reject it out of hand but i've heard
other really smart people go
that our police go listen there should
be more de-escalation
training right there should be more
training cops should be able to
use other tools other than a physical
hold immediately
or a chokehold or something like that
there should be more psychological
training
about immediately i hate when people say
that because they don't do that
immediately that is not an instinct of a
cop
it has not been the instinct in any of
the police videos we've seen even this
year do assess
it it always escalates that situation
after a
long period of peace again the george
floyd video was not nine minutes
they were dealing with him for almost 30
minutes uh you know trying to get him to
get out of the car
sir can please come out of the corporate
so you know it's so easy to be perfect
in the retrospect and say here's
18 000 different things you could have
done but when you're dealing with a
violent criminal especially
big violent criminals george floyd was
huge right right who can hurt you the
race
ray shard um jackson ray shard
rayshard brooks right in atlanta they
were so nice to him
sir can you please get out of the
vehicle you're sleeping at a wendy's
blah blah nice can you turn around we're
just going to cuff you all this stuff
yes you're right about that police
officers oh so let's look back at the
tape though tim and go
well here's how they could have
de-escalated right i mean i did feel
like
that guy was asleep in a wendy's that
guy was asleep in a wendy's
drive-through yeah that guy was asleep
in a wendy's drive-through and i've been
there
but when you're woken up you just have
to have the cops go
you just have to leave i've been asleep
and wendy's right here
so going forward on a positive note does
candace owens ever
run for office oh this is the first time
i've gotten this question
no you get it all the time i do i
do um listen i do not have any plans to
run for office at this moment
um what an answer you know everybody
people are saying candace 2024.
i've seen that on twitter maybe
how about that maybe they feel riverbay
any well by the way i wanna you you are
really
what's amazes me about you is you have a
great sense of humor
you're always willing to have a
discussion you're you're a fan of good
comedy
um i think that
the world would be a better place if
more people
had your attitude not all of your
attitudes but
the one about the one about open
dialogue and open discussion
and um i want to congratulate you on
get and being a mother thank you
are you excited about that t-minus six
weeks
are you gonna be softer when the baby
comes out does candace owens go a little
softer
when she's a mom you know i think
that the idea that candice owens is
super hard now
is more of a media caricature i'm i'm
actually quite nice
very funny it's the number one thing
people say about me when they meet me in
person is they're surprised how much of
a sense of humor i have
um and it's because the media has built
me up as this like ah
you know person like 300 style all the
time um
so yeah you go out do people recognize
you and are they friendly
for the most part yes people recognize
me everywhere i go
and yeah they're always friendly because
leftists unless they are
you know planning to be in a group of
300 antifa supporters are
fundamentally cowards so if they see me
and they don't like me they shut up
you know you're not going to approach
candace owens and be like
i think that's going to go well for you
i don't give off the energy that i'm
going to be one of those like
oh please leave me alone you know i'm
like not playing this game i'm not like
i'm not afraid of a little antifa thug
in an airport you know
yeah you know i didn't even mean that i
just met
you go out to dinner in dc uh is the
people the political establishment
are they kind of like hey candace is a
potential ally do you
ever like don't you don't have to say
who
are there ever people behind the scenes
that
talk to you that are because you have a
very big platform you have a very
uh you know big reach is there anybody
that's like hey we got to get candace on
our side
um well no i will say there are a
lot of celebrities a-list celebrities
that i speak to regularly
um and i think it would shock people you
know kanye's
probably the only one that's been out
public about his beliefs that would have
shocked me because i live
in los angeles and i know there's a lot
of people that
you know watch what you say and and and
read what you write and some of them
have a big instagram account so they can
follow me and follow
conservatives some of them don't agree
with you some of them do agree with you
but they find what you say very
interesting
right yeah i i think and i think that
that's kind of why i'm here
um is just because there's just been
such a dogmatic approach
um to culture and to politics and i just
want people to think
and i also want to make it okay to be
normal like suddenly normal people have
to shut up all of a sudden like it's
like unless you've got some
something going on or you know it's like
so i'm just like listen
i'm a happy person and it's like a lot
of these people that are trying to be
not normal are actually trying like
they're not
artistic they're not they're not like a
genuine where you'd be like oh my god
that person's a freak of nature they're
amazing
it's like someone who's truly trying to
exist outside of this spectrum for no
reason other than the fact that they
don't have much going on
i mean i know a lot of people um
that where it's like okay you have
purple hair and whatever suppose you're
non-binary but let's be honest you just
work at geico
like there's nothing wrong with it
you're just answering claims at geico
or you're an overall impressed yeah
right
they're just at oberlin college and
they're like i i want to be
interesting and special and different
yeah you know everybody
everybody wants to be a special little
snowflake um and i get that i mean you
see that of course you said in hollywood
so much too where it's like they're
complicated for no reason that's what i
mean it's like why did harry styles put
on a dress because like there's nothing
really wrong with harry styles right
he's very talented he's good looking
he's a great singer so it's like
how can i just be controversial and you
know
put myself in some weird minority box
i'm going to be a man that wears a dress
like okay we get it you know you know
like miley cyrus yeah nothing wrong with
people up with money dad's famous
i'm going to shave my head and say that
i sometimes feel like a man or woman
okay we get it you want to be a special
snowflake right but like there's nothing
wrong with you like you know
and so i i poke fun at them and it
drives them crazy because they're trying
so hard to be different
and it's just like dude just be freaking
normal it's fine like
people will like you either way you
don't have to try to be so subversive
all the time yeah i mean listen
the answer is if you want to be
different you want to be special be tim
dillon be
candace owens that's all yeah
tell everyone where to follow you if
they don't already and they probably do
follow me on the internet okay
buy my book blackout yeah blackout is
out the book is out blackout
buy that the blexit movement are you
doing any more live events
or because as soon as we can figure out
what state is allowed to have human
beings um at
in a capacity where they're allowed to
be next to each other um we're moving to
nashville
are you moving in that you're so you're
gonna move i am i'm moving to nashville
i just did zany's the comedy club in
nashville and it was great i did seven
shows i saw that you were there that
night
so that was the first that's when i
bought my house that night yeah i was
there and it was a great time and
it's a great city and i think you're
gonna love it yeah i think so too
i'm thinking one more year in la and
then i might get out of here i might go
to texas i don't know where i'm gonna go
but it's just getting
the amount of money we pay in taxes
versus what you get yeah it's stupid
prison it's just stupid i'm like why are
you why do you live there i say
something like what are you doing there
anymore
eventually they're gonna build walls to
keep you guys in because i mean
everyone's fleeing
well candace knows you and you're still
holding on last question you're still
holding on you think
you believe there's a chance trump gets
inaugurated again i mean what uh
that would be wild get this that would
be wild
you've been remarkably consistent the
whole time i will say that
this is where you do kind of win an
award you you
have been like consistent the entire
year
about what you thought was gonna happen
and where it would go
yeah exactly and we're here now so i'm
just like you know i think it's gonna go
to the supreme court and we have the
courts
and um by the way if he wins there's
gonna be a civil war
so hopefully everyone's pro-2a because
there this is not going to be
it's going to be an issue in this
country because they all actually
believe that joe biden's already the
president-elect he's not
um you know it's just he trump hasn't
conceded um
and so we'll see what happens i you know
i obviously
for the sake of the country and that's
not getting swallowed by china's uh belt
and road initiative i hope that trump
wins i hope i pray that trump wins
well if there's a civil war hide that
ring that's a real rock over there
put that in a vault if there's a civil
war i mean that thing
is that is crazy
you've done well you've done well and i
and i appreciate that and if and if
things take a turn for the worst
you could always go to your cousin mia
and she could she can sling that in the
projects you guys
you could buy three more houses trump is
what she'll say yeah trump who
i love that candace owns thank you so
much for doing this i really appreciate
it
thanks so much for having me on guys all
right thanks a lot see you later